et maintenant on applaudit consiste
aussi francis comment se passe cette
tournée à travers la france est-ce que
tu n'as pas un petit peu assez francis
de le faire des scandales sur les
plateaux de télévision dans l'unique but
de te faire remarquer mais le prends pas
mal francis
mais ça il est vexé francis nous fait
braire un professeur bénigne aucun
humour ce franc suisse francis ne prends
pas comme ça francis comment se passe
cette tournée à travers la france bien
elle se passe bien cette tournée francis
oui il se passe bien elle se bat pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux